今天咱们上第四课，第四课叫第一个故事。
第一个故事是你们的第一个故事。
好吧，我希望咱们今天这节课上完以后呢，大家都有能力，也有冲动写下自己的第一个故事。
不用担心，现在没有，不要紧。
上完这节课就有。
咱这节课叫实战课程，不实战怎么行呢？
对吧你们得实战，我得教会你们实战。
好吧。
这个第一个故事。
一般来说啊。
呃，一个创作者人生的第一个故事。
都是发自内心的。
很自我的视角。
很内在的一种感受。
甚至来自于回忆。
来自于自己的青春或者童年。
然后呢大家都觉得啊这是很我的东西，很自我的。嗯，我的笑眯眯，我把它写出来。
结果呢写出来之后发现。
每个人的第一个故事都他们一样。
男人啊一般都写什么？
黑帮片。
街头片。
战争片。
反正就是舞刀弄枪，打打杀杀。
女孩一般写什么？
青春题材。
爱情片。
是那一套。
而且往往在里边还是个受害者。
也就是说什么呢？男人崇尚武力。
女人讲究付出。
大差不差。
所以说你不要觉得这个东西是你很自我的。
都一样。
我是不建议写这种东西啊，我不建议这么写。
你看姜文的导演处女座。
阳光灿烂的日子。
一帮小伙子荷尔蒙萌栋天天干仗打来打去。
来自于他的记忆，来自于他的青春。
就是小痞子打架。
赵薇导演处女座。
致青春。
大学生呀。
几个女生在校园里的。
爱情故事呀。
这种故事呢。
真的写不出话头。
人家是成名了大腕。
他们有资格去造，我想写啥就写啥，我管你爱看不爱看，对吧？
我记得我去看致青春，我在电影院看的。
我跟朋友一块去看的。
这个片头一开始。
这几个女孩一出场。
我就知道那就知道这篇的内容是什么了，我就跟我旁边人说，我们现在可以下注打赌啊。
哪个姑娘？
会做人流。
所有的校园题材，只要是大学校园题材。
的那种故事，那种你侬我侬。
爱情调调的故事。
必然要打胎。
因为大家没东西写了。
我跟你说，为什么他们特别爱写打牌。
打开那么好，你记得吗？第一节课我跟你们说过。
呃，那个那个。
如果一个戏这个男二号有男2号，男2号要在65分钟死掉，为什么？
因为男二号是男一号性格的一部分，是男一号的一部分，一部分死掉，男一号才能蜕变。
男二号作为男一号的一部分。
死掉蜕变。
打胎更是他妈女一号身体的生命的一部分，死掉他蜕变更容易比男2号还好使，必须打。
所以说你写这类题材的话。
写不出花来。
人人都在写。
这是第一，我不推荐写这种写不出花了。
第二呢。
你这种东西是本能的写的。
你一辈子写这个吗？
你写完这个东西，你还是不会创作故事呀。
我们上这堂课要学会创造故事呀。
你没当过杀手就不写杀手戏了，对吧？有些人说，那我那是我的青春，我就是那个打架和爱情，我就会写这两样不会的。
可能的共情素材，为什么要训练？就是要做编剧，就是这基本功对吧？而且契诃夫说过。
说每个人对人性的认识。
都是来源于自己。
这句话啥意思呢？
你对最卑劣。
最下流的。
这种性格，这种行为的认知。
也是来自于你自己。
你对最善良最圣洁的那些想法行为的认知，也是来自于你自己。你不要小看你自己，你什么都干得出来。
你也什么都写了出来。
好吧。
所以。
这节课结束的时候，我是希望大家开始写一个自己的故事，但是不要给我写青春。
不要给我写街头。
好不好？
就不要写你的青春，你的街头。
我们创作一个故事，我们有方法。
我们上节课不就创造了一个故事吗？大家记得吗？
上节课讲八要素的实战应用的时候。
我们创造的那个故事叫什么来着？
啊，没有名字，但是大家一定有印象一定有印象一个。
一个警察的故事，对吧？
一个迫切想要。
殉职的警察的故事。
殉职的须这么写啊。
一个想要殉职的警察的故事。
大家记得这个故事吧？这个故事做的还挺漂亮的。
具有一定的。
观赏性。
我们说这个故事我们是怎么写出来？
你不是不会写故事吗？我这节课。
就让你写出你的第一个故事，我要教会你的方法，教会你的第一个方法就是从哪儿下手。
故事啊需要一个地方下手。
你的第一笔写什么起笔画什么好吧。
昨天这个故事咱第一笔下手下在哪呢？
就下在这个人物设定上了，就下在这个身份上了。
一个想要殉职的警察，一个成天就是找死，我要牺牲这样一个警察。
这个设定一出。
首先吸引了大家的注意力。
然后呢。
其实整个故事。
出来一半。
等于是等于说什么呢？
这个这个设定啊成为了当时我们整个故事的一个支点。
我们就是围绕这个设定，把故事搞出来了。这个设定占我们昨天那个故事。
功劳的一半。
怎么说不管是八要素，几要素，他扛了一半了。
他扛了一半了。
所以说我们昨天想出这个。
基本都会写了。
我昨天说出我们一个想要殉职的警察。
脑子好的同学自己也会写了，就不用我带着你写了，你也能写出一个版本来。
对吧因为这个。
才是故事的支点。
那么这节课就讨论一下。
是有哪些支点？
就从哪下手？我们既然发现了，我们只要有一个地方敢下手。
就能搞出一个故事。
那我们这节课去解决一个下手的问题。
还能从哪下手？
这显然是一个可以下手的地方，对吧？我们就说呃，我我写在这儿啊。
那支点来第一个支点，这个支点。
这是个什么？
这是个人物设定。
对吧。
这是个人物设定呀。
或者是用我们昨天。
呃，昨天的那个八要书里面的词。
就是个身份。
也就是说，一个好的身份。
可以成为你创造你第一个故事的下手点。
起点。
信心的源泉。
对吧你有了它之后，你就。
这里马上有谱了，我这个故事。
哎，7788了。
我心里有数了。
身份。
那我们说这样的人设，这样的身份。
可以成为我们的起点。
怎么创造呢？怎么搞呢？
其实我们昨天简单提过说你可以写一个附加值的。
定语。
对吧。
我们说。
以人设为起点的。
影视剧你能想到哪些？
比如说啊。
呃，有个美剧叫单身独妈。
一个妈妈。
而且是那种富人娶的妈妈。
看起来很呃温柔贤良。
其实呢是个毒贩。
一直在卖毒品。
而且他的目标呢就是他小孩同学的爸爸们。
等于他靠这个。
呃，贩毒赚的钱混迹于。
上流社会。
那这个他的这个定律跟他的身份就相反，价值相反。
就有戏。
这个戏就可以做。
还有啊。
那个那个逍遥医生。
这有意思。
啊，叫rush。
也是一个美剧。
对吧也是一个美剧。
那个医生。
医生我们说那穿着白大褂治病救人。
这个医生呢是个痞子医生。
像个黑社会一样，每天啊这边黑帮火拼好啊，他受枪杀了，还过来看了看哦，中了三枪来给我5万，我给他把弹头取出来，他挣这个钱挣那些。
去不了医院的人的钱。
那基本上都是跟一些犯罪分子来打交道。
所以说这样的一个医生也是我们。
认知范围以外的人设。
他就有戏就可以成为你的故事的起点。所以这类人设你就去想什么呢？一个奇怪的什么，对吧？
怎么个怪法，奇怪的啥啥一个不称职的。
啥啥。
这种可以成为你故事的起点。
到我这里呢我就不展开讲了。因为。
虽然我们昨天是用这个方法解决了故事起点的问题。
但是这个作为呃平常写作来说，它成为故事起点不是最主流的。
我们接着往下说，有好多种东西可以成为你故事的起点。第二。
激励事件。
同学说了，怎么又出新词了，激励事件又给我们搞个新词儿。
别慌，我给大家解释一下，大家就明白了，好吧。
激地事件又称干扰事件。
啥意思呢？
就是出了一个事儿。
把这个。
主角的生活给搅乱了。
干扰事件好吗？
一般来说是什么事呢？
背一个口诀好吧，叫小人物。
出大事儿。
大人物。
遇小事儿。
大家去背这个口诀。
就基本有数了。
啥意思呢？就说你这个主角啊。
虽然没有这么这么。
奇怪的人物设定。
他是一个正常设定，就我们认知范围内的设定，他就是要么就是个小人物。
要么就是个厉害人。
但是呢他遇到了一个他生活中很少遇到的事件。
我们就称这类事件为干扰事件，或者叫激励事件，引起了主角的不适不适应。那么。
我们不就有故事了吗？
那这类干扰事件一般是怎么出现的呢？就是小人物出大事，你本来是个普通的人，一下摊上一个你面对不了的大事儿，你没有经历过的大事儿，对吧？
那你。
当然是是有故事了，或者你本来是个大人物，被困在一个小事情当中，你要解决一个小事情，那不就又搞出问题了吗？我们随便举几个例子啊。
小人物出大事。
功夫熊猫。
一个煮面条的熊猫那么胖，对吧？脂肪含量那么高。
突然被选为天选之子。
要练要在短时间内速成功夫，迎迎战强敌。小人物摊上大事了吗？
对吧。
还有什么？
破坏之王。
周星驰的。
呃，送外卖的对吧？呃，送外卖的一个外卖仔。
要跟谁干仗，要跟谁他要跟谁打，他卷入了个什么事儿？
他要跟断水流大师兄打架呀，断水流大师兄是何等人也？断水流大师兄说，你们在座的都是垃圾，恕我直言，对吧？断水断水流大师兄你也敢惹。
这不就典型的小人物遇大事嘛？周星驰有。
周星驰大部分的片子都是小人物出大事，因为周星驰爱演小人物。
所以呢他的这个这个呃都是玩这一套小人物出大事儿。
功夫其实也是嘛。
对吧那个那个呃都是小人物去办大事儿。
小人物出大事，当然还有咱们这个去年刚播过的呃宁浩导演的疯狂的外星人，对吧？黄渤，你一个耍猴的。
你去耍外星人，外星人那是高等生物啊，科技比你强那么多都都超能力了，那都是一年哥这个乾坤大挪移的，他拿人当猴耍，这小人物。
醋辣式。
所以说是以激励世界为起点。
对吧你看这种故事，你设想一下他的编剧在创作的过程中，他一定第一时间想到的是。
这个干扰事件就是我写一个小人物摊上了一个什么样的大事儿，然后才开始写剧本。所以这是他故事的起点。
我们如果写故事，找不到起点，激励事件完全是可以下手的那大人物遇小事的情况多吗？
很多很多的。
比如说一个一个什么叫大人物啊，呃，就是那种传统强悍强人。
运动员。
那个那个特工警察、黑帮大佬，这都就是传统的所谓的大人物强人，他们遇小事，对吧？那个那个什么呃特特工奶爸。
一个特工去给人看孩子吗？那不就是大荣于小事了吗？对吧？困在小事里了，龙龙有浅滩，虎落平阳嘛，不就这意思吗？特工奶爸临时保姆都是走这种路子。
大人物遇小事，还有啊那个我们说周星驰喜欢搞小人物出大事儿，大人物与小事儿，他也有。
逃学威龙。
他明明是个警察，被困在。
中学校园里当学生，那不就是大人物遇小事吗？各种不适应。
当然那个那个困在学校里当学生的，还有一个更典型的。早年有个韩国电影叫头师傅一体，名字很难很拗口啊。
他讲的是什么呢？
讲的是一个黑帮大佬。
黑帮二帮家。
想要继承大佬快退休了，想要继承大佬的位置。但是呢无意中听说大佬啊选这个接班人有一个条件，说是觉得这个都已经马上21世都已经21世纪了，这个社团发展也是需要有智慧的。
咱们整个社团的最高学历是初中。我希望我的接班人呢。
是个有文化的人，要有高中学历。
追求也不是很高啊。然后呢，这个这个男一号呢，这个系的男一号呢他是初中学历，但是他有个优势，他有个优势。他照到镜子一看，哎，我要是说我19岁20岁其实也还可以啊，确实长得嫩。
然后呢，他就找了一家高中去临时去读一个高三，希望能把这个高中的文凭拿出来。那么这就是黑社会大哥困在。
黑社会大哥是大人物，强人嘛，强人遇小事，学校里面呃读书。
跟其他的高中生这去处理这些学校里的鸡毛蒜皮的事情，这就是大人误遇小事儿。
对吧就是这种套路，小人物出大事，那个呃喜剧大师都很喜欢用。除了刚才一说周星驰会想起来，金凯丽金凯瑞一直用呀。
他每部戏击乎都是这样，就是你看那个那个冒牌天神。
他就是一个很倒霉的小人物。
然后他就诅咒上帝，说你敢不敢让我当一天上帝，结果上帝说，行长，你当摊上大事。
是吧小人物出大事。
所以说你看啊激励世界。
或者所所谓的叫干扰事干扰。哎，随便了啊，干扰事件引引发的这个这个这个故事起点。
是最多的。
所以这个也严重值得我们大家去考虑。而且这个干扰事件你如果写的漂亮了，这个戏上来就是。
就会很吸引人就会很吸引人。好吧，这个我们也是可以呃值得我们严重考虑的。
就是所谓的干扰事件。我以前在讲干扰事件的时候啊，有同学问过我一个问题，我在这里我怕你们也问，我就一并给你解答了，说凭什么只有小人物出大事，大人物出小事儿就没有小人物出小事或者大人物出大事吗？那么超人不就是大人物吗？他出的事儿都挺大的，拯救地球啥的。
产生这个疑问。
我说咱家叫激励事件，干扰事件。
超人出大事超人出大事，他那是他的日常大人物办大事，那叫日常，那就不叫干扰事件，不叫激励事件。干扰事件，激励事件什么意思啊？
干扰世件激励事件是激发你的主角，改变自己的状态了，你懂我意思吧？他本来是个小人物，出上摊上大事了之后，他要改变自己的状态。
星仔。
跟断水流有大师兄要决战。
他他要开始改变自己的状态，他要开始跟达叔练功呀，对不对？他不可能继续送外卖的呀。
你送外卖。
所以这叫激励事件，大人物出大事儿，那叫日常。
它不叫干扰事件，不叫激励事件。好吧，所以这个这个呃不要去呃思考这种这种事情。
这是第二种。
如果你能想到一个激励事件，一个干扰事件，也可以成为你的故事的起点。
好吧，这是又一个可以下手的地方。
而且这种事你想到了，那你整个剧基本上已经出来了。而且我说过，如果从这儿下手，你的人设。
是倒推了是倒推了，你有一个好的激励事件了，你倒推一个人设。
你你有一个好的人设了，你往下推一个。
呃，事儿。
所以说。
你先有什么？
只要他好，你都可以。
让他生根发芽。